we're here with the phenomenal comedian
extraordinaire phoebe robinson
and she has an incredible podcast called
black frasier
because her friends feel like she is an
excellent therapist
with that we actually rounded up a
couple people to ask you
some questions phoebe are you cool with
that i'm so ready for it let's do it
okay phoebe esteban sent us a video
hey drew hey phoebe i really need your
advice on this
just got finished hanging out with my
friends but
they like to drink so they're ordering
cocktails and stuff
i don't drink but at the end of the
night when the bill comes
they just divide it up evenly whoa whoa
why am i paying for your booze but how
do i bring this up
without sounding like the cheap friend
[Music]
who that is tricky i feel like at
a certain age that's just how it is you
just divide the bill evenly and it sort
of
all equals out in the end so maybe if
they're buying booze at this dinner then
maybe next time you guys go out you
order a dessert so that sort of offsets
it and they're paying for your
cheesecake so
i would say don't bring it up just sort
of
unless you're spending you know they're
popping bottles then it's like hey
we're not in vegas it's not a bachelor
party what's going on but if it's a
you know cosmopolitan i don't know what
men drink if it's scotch
just pay for their scotch that time i
know
all right we have time for one more
michelle in los angeles
here's this video check it out hey drew
so there's an acquaintance that i have
that really wants to get together for
coffee
and so we schedule it but then i don't
really want to go
so then i cancel it and this friend is
super persistent and
keeps asking and i don't know what to do
because i really don't want to go
how do i get out of it phoebe
i think what would be good is instead of
setting up this date and then canceling
it whether it's coffee or brunch or
whatever
hop on the phone and sort of figure out
why you're not wanting to sort of
meet up with this person i know that
could be awkward but i think sometimes
like if you're feeling something you
don't express it you can just
you know put it out in a way where it's
like oh i don't want to hang out with
you rather than just talking through the
issue
and then getting stronger together as
friends because why not if it really
means that much to you and this person
you really value i think you got to do
anything you can to sort of save that
connection
phoebe i really love that because these
are difficult times
and they are putting relationships under
a microscope
that is very tricky and i don't you know
we're not hugging each other
because we're thinking does that hug
have a price tag
and it's a very complicated time and i
think getting on the phone
is a safe way to try to rekindle
bridge or connect and i think that's
really good advice oh well thank you oh
my gosh i should do your show every day
you make me feel so good about myself
i'm so glad i wore this wig for you it
is paint
it is paying off i'm so pumped thank you
well i was really excited that you would
honor the show with your presence i
followed your career i'm inspired by
what you do you lift other people up
your two dope queen show we haven't even
talked about that
and that is literally a platform where
you display
and show off all these people's talents
and
what you're putting out into the world
and how you're lifting others up
really really speaks to me because
that's how i'd like to try to live my
life
is to shine the light in the other
direction
and feature people who are doing
something for others
as well as shining themselves in the
process
well i think that's what you're doing
with your show here i mean i think it's
so
great and i'm all for women being in
daytime tv
we just have to like you said provide
this platform for other people
also you look amazing thank you i wore
this with these extensions for you
i also have a little present you
mentioned one time
that you were gonna celebrate drew
barrymore is
getting crocks or giving away crocs yes
so i'm sending these to you
the signature color of our show sunshine
and everything important in the world
happy meaningful yellow and it says
queen
phebes that way you can rock your crocs
maybe even with some socks
yes oh my god this is so amazing i can't
wait to get them and wear them around my
apartment thank you so much
this is so amazing and i love that
you're doing this show i think it's
going to be so fun and i think
especially now we're all at home like we
need to start our day with brightness as
opposed to just
turning to twitter and reading like all
the devastating news so shows like yours
are
i would say like even more important now
than ever before
thank you phoebe thank you so much thank
you everybody phoebe robinson
black frasier her podcast is available
at cvrobinson.com
[Music]
you